Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis on his maiden voyage to Iowa.
I bring greetings
from the free state of Florida,
riding a wave of lofty expectation
as to the state that opens
the Republican presidential contest
in less than a year.
People lined up
to catch a glimpse of the governor
who technically is promoting his book.
This is the number one bestselling
nonfiction book in the country, but
actually is testing a White House bid that
he intends to make official by summer.
Welcome to Iowa. This is your first trip.
DeSantis has told advisers he will wait
until the Florida legislative session ends
so he can campaign on an even bolder
agenda,
one that is delighting supporters
and alarming critics.
I always tell my legislators,
you watch Iowa, watch to watch these.
Do not let them get ahead of us
on any of this stuff.
So we've got our legislature here
in session now.
So buckle up.
The next 60 days should be fine
in Florida.
He's stoking the culture wars in schools.
We're also leading on ensuring
that our school system
is focusing on educating our kids,
not indoctrinating our kids and beyond.
We've got to fight.
If we see it in medicine,
or the universities or the corporations,
you can't just say Let it go,
because then we're going to be living
under an oppressive woke ocracy
holding up his Florida record
as a blueprint for a national platform
and presenting himself as a doer,
not a talker.
A leader is not captive to polls.
We don't have palace intrigue.
We don't have any drama.
It's just execution every single day.
I'll build the wall
myself. I'll do it this.
Let me add him we'll get it done.
That was a subtle yet unmistakable
distinction with Donald Trump,
who visits Iowa on Monday.
The 2024 Republican campaign
is intensifying with former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley
urging Iowa voters to keep an open mind.
Whatever the polls tell you today,
that is not where the polls
are going to be a year from now.
But for many Republicans, the Florida
governor stands as a beacon of hope
for those who admire Trump
but are eager to move on.
I would love to have him
as our next president.
Becky Grist.
Bock was among those eager to see DeSantis
close up.
President
Trump has been an amazing president,
but he alienates too many people
with what he says.
And I think Governor DeSantis
is doing a good job at appealing to
Americans
Now, the Florida governor just finished
shaking hands here and left the room.
And Erin, I can tell you
Republican had had high expectations
coming into this day and they are leaving
it having those expectations met.
One Republican voter here
who said they're looking for a change
described the Florida governor
as very impressive, a straight shooter.
Of course, this is probably
the easiest trip he will take to Iowa.
He had no arrows coming his direction.
He's heading to Nevada tomorrow,
another early voting state.
Of course, this is all before he decides
or announces that he's going to run.
But I am told that is expected to come
in May or early June.
Carson, we heard Governor Sanders take
a thinly veiled shot at former president
say when he talks
about how there's no drama
in his administration,
something he said before.
How long do you think it is
before the tension between the two of them
actually becomes more direct
Well, I
mean, obviously, Donald Trump
has been openly attacking him.
And the question is how much Ron DeSantis
wants to really seriously engage
with that.
I don't think it's really in his interest
to do that because I think we've seen
in the past what happens to people
who get in the mud with with Donald Trump.
You know, they ended up they end up
usually not coming out, looking not great.
And he's smarter, I think, to stay focused
on whatever issues it is
that he thinks are going to help him
win the nomination, which is the
if he decides to run, which let's face it,
he's in Iowa in early March.
He lives in Florida.
He's probably pretty serious
thinking about running for president.
That's what he's going to do.
Then he should just focus more
on the issues that he has
that excite the base.
Scott, there was reporting today
by Politico about how many of the other
Republican presidential candidates
both declared an undeclared hour,
focused on attacking Trump and DeSantis.
Their thinking is reportedly
that there's only one viable lane
for the anti-Trump vote, and therefore
they need to take the fight to dissenters.
Do you agree with that?
I do.
I think in this primary you've got Trump
and then there's
going to be one other person that emerges
and right now, if you look at DeSantis
favorability ratings
and really look at the fact
that he has virtually
no detractors inside the Republican Party,
every other Republican candidate
who wants this thing is going to have
to find a way to drag him down.
I don't know how they're going to be able
to do it, to be honest.
I'm sure they're going to try.
But he is in a different universe,
really, than every other person.
That's not Trump
that's seeking this nomination.
DeSantis has the right emotional
sort of attachment to the Republican base.
And what you see in his favorability
numbers is not only good numbers
among people who voted for Trump,
but also those college educated
Republican voters that drifted away
from the Republican Party
and drifted away from Trump.
They love DeSantis.
And so of everybody in this thing
right now,
he looks like the one
that has the capability
of putting together
the coalition that could possibly
possibly, I say, topple
the former president.
He's obviously
never run a national campaign.
Kirsten DeSantis, his allies, some of them
arguing his successes, not necessarily
because of how he campaigns,
but how he governs.
I don't know if that's
sort of laying groundwork for saying he's
not maybe a great national campaigner,
but that obviously remains to be seen.
Is that going to be enough in a state
like Iowa where retail politics
are so important?
Well, we don't really
know whether he's going to be a good
go to national politics or not.
Obviously, there are plenty of people
who haven't done it before
and have been successful.
So, I mean, Donald Trump
never had ever held office at all.
So I think we have to wait and see how he
he does on a national stage.
And the fact is,
I think if the vote was taken today,
most of the parties is with Donald Trump,
but his numbers are on the downswing.
I mean, they're definitely they used to be
And so there is an opening for a Trump
plus not.
Know, I think there's this idea of also
the people who are a little bit of less of
of the Trumpian US
I don't think there's much appetite
for that in the Republican Party.
They're looking for either a Trump or
a Trump plus a DeSantis is a Trump plus.
It's got you know, I think Democrats
are kind of betting that Governor
DeSantis, his focus on culture wars
will turn off women working class voters.
Do you think moderate swing
state voters care very much when he boasts
that Florida is where vote goes to die?
You think that plays well?
Well, I mean, the only evidence
I have to look at on this is what happened
in his reelection campaign in Florida,
that he won by 20 points.
Urban, suburban rural, exurban
people with college degrees, people
without college degrees, independents.
I mean, women, men.
I mean, any way you slice and dice
humanity, Ron
DeSantis did a pretty darned
good job of racking up votes in Florida.
So I think the message he's been running
on, you know,
we've had one test case for it
and it seemed to work.
I'll tell you, Anderson, the average
Republican feels surrounded right now.
They feel like every large information
distribution information
hub in our society
is really at odds with their worldview,
whether it's corporations,
universities, media,
you name it, politicians,
government institutions.
And they feel like
DeSantis is the person
who does more than just complain about it.
He actually finishes the fights.
I think that's the line of demarcation
for him.
Everybody in this field can complain.
I can finish it.
You know,
I ask the security and I just want to
I wanted to ask you, Scott,
do you think these candidates know?
I mean, do you think the world knows
how to campaign against Donald Trump
from a Republican standpoint?
Because, I mean,
here we are all these years later
and we're still talking about Will.
Should Ron DeSantis directly
attack him or not?
We have a whole field of defeated
candidates.
You know, Jeb Bush among them,
Marco Rubio,
who tried all different
ways and none of it worked.
Now, I think all the
Republicans from 2016 forward are like
the Will Smith character and I am legend.
They're in the lab and they're like
testing all the theories, the serums out
and the rats keep dying like
they can't figure out how to solve it.
Maybe, maybe Ron
DeSantis is the one to solve it.
But we don't know yet because the theory
he's going to test out is to put results
up against rhetoric and to put a younger
generation up against an older generation.
We just haven't seen this
particular concoction yet.
Maybe we'll put it in the lab in Iowa
or New Hampshire or other places,
and it will work.
But but no, no one has
successfully campaigned against him yet
except one person.
And that was Joe Biden
who defeated Donald Trump.
And we know what will happen.
I think as a Republican,
I know what will happen
if we nominate Donald Trump again.
Kirsten,
if my memory of the ending of I Am Legend,
I don't want to give away for anybody
who might want to watch it on television,
but it doesn't end well for Will Smith
at the end of the movie.
Is there a right way for DeSantis
to respond to Trump when he decides to?
I don't think it's a good idea
to get into it with Donald Trump.
I think you know, don't let Donald Trump
say what he's going to say.
But trying to get, as I said,
trying to get into the mode with him
is not ever going to work
well for anybody.
I think it's better for him to
you know, to respond
based on the issues that that concern him,
but not get into these
petty little name games
and all these other things, which even
the people who like Donald Trump say
they don't really like that much.
Right. A lot of times they're like this.
We don't really need this.
Not really adding a lot.
All the little nicknames that you give
everybody so,
you know, but he's going to
you know, he's already going after him.
He needs a better nickname.
Let's be honest.
I don't think the sanctimonious
is probably going to do it,
but he's he's
going to continue to go after him.
But I do think that Ron DeSantis
is qualitatively different
than the other people that I don't know
what Scott thinks about this.
But then from the other people that
ran the last time, I think
he's a different kind of politician
and it is a little more connected
with the base.
Yeah. Scott Jennings
can totally agree with that. Yeah.
Yeah,
she what she what she just said, Anderson.
100% correct.
People are trying to compare him
to the candidates in 2016.
His numbers and his connection
with Republicans is vastly different
than anybody Trump faced before.
That's why Trump, I think, is already in
sort of many freak out mode about.